[Música]
hola buenas tardes
el día de hoy vengo a hablarles de un
poquito de nuestra realidad y también de
nosotros mismos
hablar de méxico siempre me inflama el
pecho
el problema es de cual méxico hablamos
hay muchos mexico´s hay una infinidad de
versiones de nuestro país
en méxico tenemos en méxico de las
ciudades en méxico del campo el méxico
indígena el méxico de los ricos en
mexico de los pobres el méxico de los
políticos y de todos los mas
diario en mi profesión veo muchos
problemas me dedico a resolver problemas
los problemas de cada uno de nosotros
pero incluso esos problemas
tienen un problema mayor que es que
todos tenemos problemas en común todos
tenemos problemas como país
hay una cuestión muy curiosa
a todos nos molestan los mismos
problemas pero si todos tenemos los
mismos problemas
porque no hemos encontrado la solución
porque lo que nos sobra es voluntad
todos nos enfrentamos con la corrupción
con la impunidad con la inseguridad
porque no hemos sido capaces como
sociedad de ponerles un alto
de lo que vengo a hablar el día de hoy
es de que quizás lo que nos hace falta
para solucionar todos estos problemas
son únicamente tres cosas igualdad
libertad y fraternidad entre los
mexicanos
por qué
en alguna ocasión
cuando el maestro rius vino a estas
ciudades son luis potosí
yo le hice una pregunta
maestro
usted me puede dar
un símbolo
que no sea religioso que no sea cívico
que no sea deportivo en el que nos
identifiquemos todos los mexicanos
la cara de los demás integrantes ese día
fue de noche social todos la bandera por
la bandera no
si tuviéramos un símbolo en común hoy en
día en la calle indio no seguiría siendo
un insulto no seguiría siendo un
insulto
no habría discriminación no había
problemas de integración hemos llegado a
tal punto que hoy en día en nuestro país
nacer en ciertas zonas o bajo ciertas
condiciones es prácticamente una
sentencia al rezago a la marginación
jamás podrán acceder a las oportunidades
a las que otros quizás con mucha suerte
o con fortuna pudimos acceder
ya qué se debe todo esto han escuchado
quizás que el mexicano es el peor
enemigo de otro mexicano tanto dentro
como fuera de nuestras fronteras porque
se debe esto
si nos ponemos a reflexionar
no nos hemos tomado el tiempo como
sociedad de conciliar nuestro pasado de
ser capaces de reconocer un pasado en
común y un futuro único porque el
mexicano es muy solidario muchísimo
durante los pasados eventos del mes de
septiembre en el que nos hemos sembrado
otra vez como pocas veces en nuestra
historia vimos la sociedad civil como
siempre grandes muestras de solidaridad
pero esa solidaridad no es lo mismo que
ser fraterno una persona que es fraterna
es una persona que se identifica con su
congénere es una persona que es capaz de
verse a sí misma reflejada en el otro
a los mexicanos nos hace falta ese
sentido de fraternidad nos hace falta
entender que como sociedad somos el
producto
de una gran mezcla lanza y amalgama de
culturas que esa gran diversidad que se
ve reflejada en las regiones de nuestro
país nuestro país es diverso como
nosotros mismos y es precisamente esa
diversidad la que nos vuelve ricos
desafortunadamente no nos damos cuenta
de esta diversidad sino hasta que cuando
a alguien más usualmente de otras
latitudes del globo nos dice méxico es
muy grande méxico es muy rico méxico es
muy bello decimos así cierto sí sí es
muy rico sí sí es muy bello yo soy
mexicano pero no somos capaces de traer
ese sentido de pertenencia
en el día a día de nuestras vidas no
hemos podido ver que en el indígena en
aquel descendiente afroamericano de
oaxaca en las colonias de extranjeros
que viven en nuestro país simplemente en
los distintos estratos sociales están
nuestra riqueza debemos ser capaces de
hombro a hombro e incluir esa
biodiversidad y esa diversidad de
culturas en nosotros mismos
porque -dijo- que también nos hace falta
libertad méxico es un país de libertades
tenemos una gama impresionante libertad
de culto libertad de expresión libertad
de tránsito
yo no requiero ningún tipo de permiso
para agarrar un transporte en mi coche
bueno la patineta si yo quiero ir a
cualquier la actitud de este país
tenemos un país tan libre que podríamos
llamar el país de la libertad es sin
embargo me gustaría comentarles que la
libertad que yo veo que le falta a este
país es la libertad de entenderse a sí
mismo un país libre es un país culto
méxico es un país de una gran cultura
pero tener una gran cultura no es ser un
país culto un país culto es aquel que se
ha aceptado a sí mismo que es capaz de
ver en la diversidad la unidad
un país culto es aquel que comprende que
garantizando respetando y sobre todo
haciendo imponer los derechos y
libertades de cada quien es la única
manera de ser libre en la manera en que
yo respete tu derecho seré libre
méxico es un país que no ha entendido
tan así sus libertades que llevamos
décadas luchando por hacer que se
respeten libertades de las mujeres
libertades de las minorías libertades de
los pueblos indígenas de la equidad de
género y preferencias sexuales
están en estas leyes sin embargo
nosotros somos los que estamos juzgando
esas propias libertades en el sentido en
el que no comprendemos que desde el
motivo y desde el momento en el que
somos tan amplios y tan diversos
debemos respetar y aprender a convivir
uno con otro el día que yo pueda
expresarme libremente en cuanto mis
ideas en cuanto mis convicciones sin que
alguien más venga a coartar las obtenga
que defenderlas no solo de los demás
sino incluso de la propia autoridad ese
día estaremos en un país verdaderamente
libre
un país culto es aquel que tiene la
capacidad suficiente para ver cómo lo
decía maquiavelo desde las alturas tener
esa perspectiva de que el amplio marco
de la gran imagen que es méxico es
precisamente lo que nos hace libres lo
que nos hace ser nosotros mismos
por otra parte dijo que en méxico
también nos falta y nos falta más
incentivar lo que es la igualdad porque
a pesar de que inclusive en nuestra
máxima ley que es la constitución dice
los hombres y las mujeres son iguales
ante la ley y la ley está bien está bien
es evidente
tenemos una cuestión de que la igualdad
empieza desde el momento en el que
nosotros mismos somos desiguales
nosotros mismos somos los que generamos
la desigualdad que después se traduce en
esa corrupción que nos tiene tan hartos
en esa impunidad que nos tiene tan
hartos y en la inseguridad que no nos
permite salir de nuestras casas de una
manera tranquila de una manera segura
porque digo que nos hace falta que
nosotros mismos somos quienes estamos
generando esta cuestión de desigualdad
esto comienza desde casa desde el
momento en el que no nos tratamos
iguales como hombres y como mujeres
porque tenemos ese arraigo cultural de
separar cuando uno separa lo que es
igual crea la inequidad en este país
nacemos iguales nacimos iguales en la
comunidad más alejada de la montaña en
la costa en el desierto donde quiera en
este país tenemos derecho a tener el
mismo acceso a las posibilidades que
todos los demás
en el sentido tenemos que un problemita
cultural que muchas veces se nos nos
parece un poco gracioso pero que es una
realidad
el mexicano es el anárquico por
autonomasia
mira este amarillo
no tirar basura tirada sobre no no se
puede como no yo puedo ya eras
cuando no se enfrenta siempre a
situaciones por ejemplo tiene la la
policía y oye yo soy hijo y todos somos
parientes del presidente de los
senadores que tú quieras
tenemos esta mala costumbre de querer
burlar a la autoridad desde el momento
en el que yo digo a ver cómo lo hago
para no pagar impuestos no
la única manera de conservar la igualdad
que hemos ganado a lo largo de la
historia es a través del cumplimiento
irrestricto de la ley sin burla' la ley
no se pone por encima nos pone a todos
por debajo
él se hace a un lado tratando de evitar
el cumplimiento si estamos hartos de la
corrupción pero la corrupción tiene dos
partes el que ofrece y el que recibe si
tenemos autoridades corruptas pero la
corrupción empieza con nosotros mismos
una cuestión muy curiosa del arte es que
si uno le presta la suficientemente
atención se va a percatar que siempre se
adelanta siempre te avisa de los cambios
que van a venir en la sociedad si hoy en
día tenemos en nuestra sociedad un
panorama tan adverso es porque esa
adversidad la hemos ocasionado y la
traemos con nosotros mismos desde el
momento en el que yo decido cumplir con
lo que tengo que hacer puedo exigirle a
otro que lleva a cabo su cumplimiento la
impunidad de la corrupción se acaban
pero se acaban con el poder de la
mayoría el día en el que todos decidamos
cumplir con lo que tenemos que hacer y
exigir el cumplimiento del derecho de
los demás ese día todos podemos más que
ese sistema del cual estamos hartos
el respeto al cumplimiento de las normas
que nos dan esas amplias libertades nos
van a volver libres
efectivamente hay que ponernos al margen
de la corrupción y de la impunidad todos
podemos acabar con los grandes males que
nos aquejan siempre y cuando todos
exijamos el cumplimiento cuando yo
cumplo puede exigir te responsablemente
que cumples si soy parte del problema no
puedo formar parte de la solución
es una solución está en cada uno de
nosotros
hay problemas por supuesto que los hay
pero las soluciones de nosotros mismos
si tratamos a los igual a los demás de
una manera igualitaria de una manera
fraterna tratando bajo el marco de
nuestra sociedad y del respeto el
cumplimiento de tus libertades
independientemente de tus preferencias
independientemente de tus creencias por
el simple hecho de ser mexicano
ese día vamos a dar un paso hacia
adelante en este país
hay una canción
tiene unas frases que me gusta mucho
y creo que valdría la pena
que grabáramos en esto subconsciente
en méxico siembra la historia porque en
méxico surge la gloria yo creo en méxico
igual creo en méxico libre creo en un
méxico fraterno porque la gloria de
méxico no está en mí y está en ti está
en todos nosotros vayamos por ese méxico
que queremos si podemos
[Aplausos]